well the 30s the day I was born in 1934
and as you're right that oppression was
on I think I am I can legitimately
consider myself a child of the
depression and that nobody had anything
and so when you're not used to having
something when you do have something you
appreciate it a lot more and because
everybody was in the same boat there was
also a kind of an affinity of of misery
and and as a consequence there was no
misery in other words if everybody's
suffering the same way the same thing
there was a kind of we're all in this
together and I felt that with my as a
kid and and then World War two came and
I we lived in Kansas and Wichita Kansas
where they built the b-17s and the b-29s
my mother in fact worked on the assembly
line of the b-29 as a wire cutter and
the Boeing plant in Wichita and world
war two and we thought that the Japanese
were going to bomb us any moment because
we had the Boeing plant there there's
after Pearl Harbor but what did what it
did for me is the war was was very
present even though it was you know
physically very very far away it was
very much part of our lives and my dad
had been a marine in the 1920s I decided
right then and there that someday I
would grow up to be a marine and so did
my older brother and as a matter of fact
that's what happened but all that stuff
kind of began there that that here again
the world war two was similar in to the
depression in that there was a
togetherness about it and it wasn't
wasn't him and her and the them and they
was all of us at war all of us doing the
best we could to to beat the bad guys
and to protect ourselves from the bad
guys and there is a so I think frankly
I am fortunate I know it sounds strange
but I am fortunate that I did have the
depression in World War two in those
early years because it I I never ever
because of those two experiences
day-to-day experiences in both cases I
have never ever been somebody who took
anything for granted because I because I
just it was part of my growing up and
part of my my formation is who I am
today I think that it all began with you
know wondering where we can have enough
money to have dinner tonight whether or
not somebody next to me or some member
of my family was going to die in a war
it made everything it heightened
everything heightened awareness
heightened interest heightened intensity
of life and I still feel that the
depression touched everybody world war
two touched everybody these calamities
that I'm talking about do not touch
everybody just automatically just by
their very nature what I'm suggesting is
the variable here it is that the country
the leaders of our country and thus and
the leaders meaning the people the
population must accept and be encouraged
to accept the fact that we are all
touched by calamities and in a ways that
we don't we didn't happen we didn't have
to be in the depression or being world
war two to understand that this was our
calamity that Iraq was our client Darfur
is our calamity we have when there is a
calamity we have a stake in it and we
have a responsibility but that has to we
have that has to be the whole society
our star every element family school
church whatever as well as the political
system and primarily the political
system has to be built on that and the
people who are running for office
presence of the United States candidates
for president of the United States and
my opinion everyone up I don't care if
you're a left-wing
right winger republican a democrat and
independent should tell the people the
very worst and say okay i can fix this
but i can't do it alone here's what you
could do and ask people to help and be
very specific about it and some
sometimes you may have to pay more taxes
oh okay well alright sometimes you may
have to do that sometimes you know and
make us all but but it's got to be it's
got to be a it's going to be a culture
it's going to be a politician the
politicians argue and debate about how
they're going to resolve these things
and how they're going to affect how
everybody is going to be affected about
about it and what they can all do about
it rather than right now politicians
tend to talk into they want to make
everything alright we can you know the
law make it all so simple and so easy
none of this is simple and easy and to
act like we can we can go to war and and
only touch a few people in the
volunteering military and their families
that's what happened and now it's not
working and it's beginning to touch more
and more people more more people get
stuck get touched the more and more
questions get asked and the more and
more everything every morning every
thing becomes more more difficult
you